you're not angry that I sent for you it
it was necessary for me to see
you serious and Stern set of her lips he
could see behind the veil immediately
changed his state of mind I
angry but how did you come why here
don't never mind come we must talk he
understood something had happened that
this meeting was not going to be joyful
in our presence he had no will of his
own not knowing the reason for our
anxiety but he already felt that this
same anxiety
involuntarily communicated itself to him
what is it what she walked a few steps
in silence Gathering her courage and
suddenly
stopped I didn't tell you
yesterday that on the way home with
Alexi
alexandrovich
I told him
everything I said that I could not be
his wife
that I told him everything he listened
to her involuntary leaning his whole
body towards her as if wishing in this
way to soften the difficulty of her
situation but as soon as she'd said it
she suddenly straightened up and his
face acquired a proud and Stern
expression yes yes it's better a
thousand times
better I understand how diffult it was
but she wasn't listening to his words
she was reading his thoughts in the
expression of his face she couldn't have
known that his expression reflected the
first thought that occurred to him that
a duel was now inevitable the thought of
a duel had never entered her head and
therefore she explained this momentary
expression of sternness differently
having received her husband's letter she
already knew in the depths of her soul
everything would remain as before that
she would be unable to scorn her
position to leave her son Unite herself
with her lover the morning spent at
princess TCO had confirmed her still
more in that but all the same this
meeting was extremely important to her
she hoped it would change their
situation and save her if at this news
he should say to her resolutely
passionately without a moment's
hesitation abandon everything and fly
away with me she would leave her son and
go with him but the news did not produce
in him what she expected he only seemed
insulted by something it wasn't the
least bit difficult it got done by
itself I understand I understand he
interrupted taking the letter without
reading it and trying to calm her I
wished for one thing I asked for one
thing to break up this situation in
order to devote my life to your
happiness why are you telling me that
could could I possibly doubt it if I did
who's that coming vonsky says suddenly
pointing at two lady IES coming towards
them maybe they know us he hastened to
turn down a sidewalk drawing her after
him I I don't
care as I said that is not the point I
cannot doubt that but there is what he
writes here is what he writes to me read
it again as in the first moment at the
news of her break with her husband
vonsky while reading the letter
involuntarily yielded to the Natural
impression aroused in him by his
attitude towards insulted husband now as
he held the letter in his hands he
involuntarily pictured to himself the
challenge he'd probably find today or
tomorrow the duel itself during which
he'd sand with the same cold and proud
expression now on his face having fired
into the air awaiting the insulted
husband's shot and at once there flashed
into his head what he himself had
thought that morning that it was better
not to bind himself and he knew he
couldn't tell her her this thought
having read the letter he raised his
eyes to her and there was no firmness in
his look she understood at once he had
already thought it over to himself she
knew that whatever he might tell her he
would not say everything he thought and
she understood her last hope had been
disappointed this was not what she had
expected one of the most
[Music]
um
we straight on to um the next thing
because another great thing the
extraordin thing about why I think
Tolstoy felt that um he sort of had
mixed feelings didn't like
theatricality so much because the great
drama in all tol sto's um writing the
greatest drama are interior monologues
he invents stream of Consciousness
writing I'm sure James Joyce actually
took a lot often the right the the
speech is broken and that these gaps
what is actually said is often portrayed
by bodyy language rather than actually
the words themselves and one of the
greatest passages a stream of
Consciousness so Fierce is and it's
taken directly from tolstoy's life is
when Levin the second hero really the
hero of the male hero of the book and
this again is out of time it speaks to
us all how many parents in here you're
all parents so except for kit who is
going to be one as well as a
star this is what happens when Levin is
waiting for the birth of his child uh
his wife
Kitty he did not know whether it was
late or
early the candles were all burning low
Dolly had just come to the study to
suggest that the doctor lie down Levan
sat there listening to the doctor tell
about a quack mesmerist and watching the
ashes of his
cigarette it was a period of rest and
he'd become
oblivious he'd entirely forgotten what
was going on now he listened to the
doctor's story and understood
it suddenly there was a scream unlike
anything he had ever heard the scream
was so terrible that Levan didn't even
jump up but holding his breath gave the
doctor a frightened questioning look the
doctor cocked his head to one side
listening and smiled approvingly
it was all so extraordinary that nothing
any longer astonished Levin probably it
should be so he thought and went on
sitting whose scream was
it he jumped up ran tiptoe to the
bedroom went round elizabeta petrona and
the princess and stood in his place at
the head of the bed the screaming had
ceased but something was changed now
what he did not see or understand nor
did he want to see and understand but he
saw it from lizabeta petron's face her
face was Stern and pale and still juts
Resolute though her Jaws twitched a
little and her eyes were fixed on Kitty
Kitty's burning tormented face with a
strand of hair stuck to her sweaty
forehead was turned to him and sought
his eyes her raised hands asked for his
seizing his hands in her sweaty hands
she started pressing them to her face
don't leave don't leave I'm afraid I'm
afraid she spoke quickly Mama take my
earrings they bother me you're not
afraid oh God s
elizabeta P soon she spoke quickly
quickly and tried to smile but suddenly
her face became distorted and she pushed
him away from her no it's terrible I'll
die I'll die go go she cried and again
came that scream that was unlike
anything in the
world Levin clutched his head and ran
out of the
room he knew that all was now
lost leaning his head against the
doorpost he stood in the next next room
and heard a shrieking and Howling such
as he had never heard before and he knew
that these cries were coming from what
once had been
Kitty he had long ceased wishing for the
child he now hated this child he did not
even wish for her to live now he only
wished for an end to this terrible
suffering doctor what is it what is it
my God he said seizing the doctor by the
arm as he came in it's nearly
over
and the doctor's face was so serious as
he said it that Levan understood this
nearly over to mean she was
dying forgetting himself he ran into the
bedroom the first thing he saw was
lizabeta patna's face it was still more
Stern and frowning Kitty's face was not
there in place of it where it used to be
was something Dreadful both in its
strange look and in the sound that came
from it he lent his head against the
wooden bedstead feeling his heart was
bursting the terrible screaming would
not stop it became still more terrible
and then as if reaching the final limit
of the
terrible it suddenly
stopped Levin did not believe his
ears but there could be no
doubt the screaming
stopped and there was a quiet
stirring a rustle and quick
breathing and her
faltering alive gentle and happy voice
softly said it's
over he raised his
head her arms resting strengthless on
the
blanket remarkably beautiful and quiet
she silently looked at him and tried but
was unable to
[Music]
smile
it you ain't heard nothing
yet it nearly is over but the last the
last section we're going to give you is
actually my favorite in all of TL sto's
writing it comes from great climactic
moment in War and Peace and too really
is as a lot of people have noticed two
writers the writer of the of power of
the public world of the absurdity of
history but he's also the writer of you
as you've been listening to of the
intensity and complicated truth of the
passions between men and women Between
Brothers and brothers and friends and
sisters and children and parents and all
these things come together at a
particular moment the moment is this
Natasha the extraordinary EX exuberant
girl at the heart of War and Peace who's
based actually on too's own wife's
younger sister Tatiana
Tanya has been engaged to be married to
the cold brilliant Prince Andre who like
an idiot has said we have to wait for a
year to see if it really is going to be
good and during the year which is
unbearable for someone of Natasha's warm
blood she almost elopes she just she
falls in love with someone who's already
married as we discovered anatol KAG in a
beautiful no goodnik a technical Russian
term and and she's discovered and she's
disgraced and what happens to this life
force of War and Peace is that she
becomes ill she hates everybody she
hates her family she who would love them
all she hates herself she's close to
dying of all this terrible feeling and
then eventually somehow this spectral
spectral race of a girl comes back to
life and looking on all the time is
Pierre Bez another version of to story
Pierre who' wanted Andre and Natasha to
be married but who finds himself caught
between them he wants to be a friend to
Nasha but something inside his heart and
his body and his head also wants to be
something more most of all he wants to
somehow he can't he knows he can't bring
Natasha and Pierre back together but
most of all watch no you can't of course
not you told told story no this you
know let's just do it let's just do this
here Natasha wasted with a pale and
Stern face not at all shamefaced as
Pierre expected her to be was standing
in the middle of the drawing room when
Pierre appeared at the door way she
became flustered obviously undecided
whether to go to him or wait for him
Pierre hastily went up to her he thought
that she would give him her hand as
always but coming close to him she
stopped breathing heavily and lowering
her arms lifelessly in exactly the same
pose in which she came out to the middle
of the room to sing but with quite a
different expression
pich Prince
boski was your
friend is your friend she corrected
herself it seemed to her that everything
only was and that now it was all
different he told me then to turn to you
Pierre sniffed silently looking up at
her up to then he had reproached her in
his soul and had tried to despise her
but now he felt such pity for her that
there was no room in his soul for
reproach he's here now tell him to um
f forgive me she stopped and began to
breathe still more rapidly she did not
cry yes yes
yes I I I I'll tell him but uh he did
not know what to say Natasha was evently
afraid of the thought that might have
occurred to
Pierre no I know it's all over no it it
can never be I'm only tormented by the
wrong I've done
him tell him only that I beg him to
forgive me to forgive me for
everything her whole body Shook and she
sat down on a chair
a feeling of pity such as he had never
experienced before overflowed Pierre's
Soul I'll tell him I'll tell him
everything once
more but I'd like to know one
thing what I'd like to
know whether you
loved Pierre did not know what to call
anatol and he blushed at the thought of
him whether you you loved
that that bad
man don't call him
bad but uh I don't know I don't know
anything she began to cry again a still
greater feeling of pity tenderness and
love took hold of
Pierre he felt tears flowing behind his
spectacles and hoped they would not be
noticed let's not talk anymore my
friend it seems so strange suddenly for
Natasha to hear that Meek tender
heartfelt voice let's not talk my friend
I'll tell him everything but one thing I
ask
you consider me your
friend and if you need help advice
or simply to pour out your soul to
somebody not now but when your soul is
clear remember
me I'll be happy to if I'm
able to me like that I'm not worthy of
it she was about to leave the room but
Pierre held her back by the hand he knew
he had something more to tell her but
when he said it he was surprised at his
words himself stop it stop it you have
your whole life ahead of
you of me
no for me All Is Lost All Is
Lost if I were not I but the handsome
brightest and best man in the world and
I was free I would go on my knees this
minute and ask for your hand and your
love Natasha for the first time in many
days wept tears of gratitude and
tenderness and after glancing at Pierre
left the room Pierre too following her
almost ran out to the front hall holding
back the tears of tenderness and
happiness that choked him put on his
coat and missing the sleeves got into
the sleigh where to now sir asked The
Coachman where
to Pierre asked
himself where can I go now not to the
club or to pay
visits all people seemed so pitiful so
poor in comparison with a feeling of
tenderness and love he experienced in
comparison with that softened grateful
glance she'd given him at the last
moment through her
tears home said Pierre throwing open the
bare skin coat on his broad joyfully
breathing chest despite the 10° of
frost it was cold and
clear above the city semi darkk streets
above the black rofs stood the Stark
Starry
Sky only looking at the sky did Pierre
not feel the insulting baseness of
everything Earthly compared with the
height his soul had risen to at the
entrance to arbat square the huge
expanse of the dark Starry Night opened
out to Pier's eyes almost in the middle
of that sky over preist densky Boulevard
stood the huge bright Comet of the Year
1812 surrounded strewn with stars on all
Skies but different from them in its
closeness to the Earth its white light
and long raised tail the same Comet
which presaged as they said all sorts of
Horrors and the end of the
world but for
Pierre this bright star with its long
luminous taale did not arouse any
frightening feeling on the
contrary Pierre his eyes wet with tears
gazed joyfully at this bright star which
having flown with inexpressible speed
through immeasurable space on its
parabolic course suddenly like an arrow
piercing the Earth seemed to have struck
here it's one chosen spot in the black
sky and stopped its tail raised
energetically its white light shining
and playing among the countless other
shimmering
Stars it seemed to Pier that this star
answered fully to what was in his
softened and encouraged Soul now
blossoming into New
Life
I